hope you all are enjoying the class so
far it's it's always interesting we have
people with a variety of backgrounds
here so it's just great to kind of hear
the questions as we're going along so
I'm going to give a quick example to
begin the class right now they kind of
drive in some of the concepts that we
talked about on the first class but this
is kind of real rather than sort of
cartoon neural networks but it's sort of
a real research result that that we have
before I begin I'd like to thank Emily
Joe who was one of my graduate students
who actually did all the work I just put
some of the slides together for not even
all of them just a few so really the
credit for this work goes to Emily
anything I misrepresent is my fault if
not hers
she graduated so I'll take the paper
that's not interesting so with that
we'll begin so all right so the overall
goal of this project was really to
detect and classified Network attacks
from real internet traffic and in order
to do this as many of you can imagine we
had to find a dataset that was of
interest so this is probably a problem
any of you are currently thinking about
which is what data set should I get my
hands on right so we have a variety of
data sets some are sensitive in nature
right so think of internal network
traffic that we're trying to collect no
one's going to let us end this you know
and silver to graduate students to kind
of work on and then more
publish so the first thing that we
wanted to do was look for a dataset that
was kind of open and out there and we
were fortunate that there is a group in
Japan called the Maui working group
which stands for the measurement and use
my measurement and analysis of wide area
Internet traffic working group that
actually has a tiny link that they've
tapped using a network app and they
actually make this data available it's
actually continuously updated even to
today so that's really cool and this is
within that its thing called the day in
the life of the Internet and so this has
been going on for multiple years the
data sets reasonably large when you
convert it into what we call an analyst
friendly form which is something that
you are I could read and make some sense
out of it's about 20 terabytes in size
so reasonably large data set not going
to fit on a single computer or a single
node so certainly a good use case for
using high performance computing their
supercomputing and one additional piece
that we should know this is something
that as you're starting off your
projects you may also think about IP
addresses are often seen as reasonably
sensitive right so you can see where
traffic is coming and going from so in
this particular data set they've
actually deterministically anonymized
each of the IP addresses and as you're
downloading the data you have to
essentially sign the user agreement
saying that you will not attempt to kind
of go back and figure out what the
original IP addresses were so as you're
coming up with the data sets and I think
Jeremy's going to talk a lot more about
this in the in the next part you might
think about you know are there certain
fields in the data that I'm collecting
that might be deemed sensitive either
today or in the future
and if so are there just simple
techniques that I could use to anonymize
the data and then with a with a decent
and user agreement you might be able to
enforce some level of you know people
not trying to break it and trying to go
back it's not impossible to do it but
any legitimate researcher who's using
data really shouldn't care about what
the original IP addresses in this
particular case are or maybe other such
data within whatever you're collecting
all right so just a great definition of
anomaly detection I really love this
definition of what an outlier is from
paper by Hawkins so an outlier is an
observation that deviates so much from
other observations as to arouse
suspicion that it was generated by a
different mechanism so when we're
looking at network traffic that's what
we're looking for right we're looking
for these mechanisms that are present in
network traffic that deviates so much
from normal behavior that it arouses
suspicion and it could be from over up
for a variety of reasons it could be
somebody uploaded this cool video of you
know somebody falling flat on their face
or it could be a botnet or a DDoS attack
or something like that so outlier could
be sometimes referred to as an anomaly
surprise or exception and within the
context of cyber networks these
mechanisms can be botnets C and C or
command & Conquer servers insider
threats or any other network attacks
such as distributed denial of service or
port scan attacks
there are a number of general techniques
to deal with outlier detection so the
first one is to look for changes is to
essentially use statistics you take you
look at the you know what's going on in
your mechanism and you look for
statistical anomalies from that and that
those of you you'll highlight those
anomalies and then you'll kind of drive
deep into that you could do clustering
so if you're looking at unsupervised
learning you could cluster your data and
things that are really far away from
existing clusters or known clusters
something that you want to take a look
at you could move similar to that is
also distance based technique so these
are kind of closely related that you
look for observations that vary
significantly from other observations in
some sort of a feature space and finally
you can use a model-based technique
where you attempt to model the behavior
of normal right now you use air quotes
for the word normal and then you come
and you look for things that deviate
from this background model so all these
four techniques are approaches to a nod
leaders are kind of related with each
other it's not a hard and fast rule
about how they deviate from each other
but for the popularity and the
complexity of network traffic we decided
to go with a model-based technique
because we found that any other means of
trying to represent the data would be
difficult so this is sort of a top-down
approach of how we kind of thought about
well let's look at network traffic let's
think about anomalies in network traffic
and let's come up with what's a good
approach to to address that so when we
talk about network attacks not to go
into detail there is a wide variety of
network attacks out there you know every
day we see news articles about new ones
the focus of this work
to look at just a couple of these one
was in this section that we call probing
and scanning and another was in this
resource usage or resource utilization
area and specifically we looked at port
scanning and distributed denial of
service attacks as a quick example of
what happens in one of these network
attacks so this is a attack often in
within the bucket of probing and
scanning so essentially what happens is
you have an attacker that attempts to
find out what ports are open on a victim
or a target system it does this by
sending requests similar to pings
to to a victim or a target system if the
target system acknowledges one of these
things you can say oh this particular
port is open and then one may go and
look at what software typically runs on
those ports and attempt to use some of
the known vulnerabilities of that
software right so a lot of software
packages have specific ports that they
tend to use so you can say oh you know
port the guy making up a number here for
10,000 is open and I know that's used by
by Microsoft SQL Server or any other
piece of software and then you can say
well here's a known vulnerability that I
could use and then I'll try attacking
that so this is just a simple technique
that a lot of attackers use very low bar
very easy to do you could write one by
mistake but just to find out what for so
and then trying to use you know in
vulnerabilities or every works now the
least common denominator the the easiest
piece of data to collect is what's
called a network packet I'm sure many of
you are familiar with the concept of a
network packet it's for those that are
not think of if you're sending a letter
it's all the material on the envelope
right so it's the address where it's
coming from who it's going to plus a
little bit of information of sort of
what's in the packet as well the reason
that we often use network packets and
I'll kind of open this up to the class a
lot of the cyber research actually
focuses on network packets but those
often form a very small percentage of
the actual data the payloads we're
actually a lot of the data actually is
can anyone guess why we tend to use a
network packets rather than payloads not
Alber head or oh sorry in the network
header yep sorry the network header not
the packet yeah so yes anyone guess why
we tend to use the header rather than
the PAP then the payload of the packet
encrypted yeah encryption exactly so
very often especially these days the
payload of the packet is typically
encrypted so there's not too much that
you can do with it so using the header
information the header is not right it's
the outside of the envelope the inside
of the envelope is something that you
cannot see by putting it up to the light
so it actually they tend to use me the
header of the packet so the headers so
this is what a packet looks like on the
on the left side that's what a packet
looks like and if you kind of convert
that into a human readable form just a
header information this is the type of
data that you get out of it so it gives
you things that you would expect what
was the IP address that I started from
what was a port that I started from what
was the destination IP address what was
the port you know the destination port
plus a bunch of other information about
certain flags that were said whether
it's what direction the flow in what
direction the traffic is moving in and
stuff like that and then any flags
associated with it what type of packet
it is of what type of protocol is a
packet using etc all right so just as a
reminder the data we're using is from
the Maori working group but there's a
lot of other data out there that you
might be able to to get your hands on so
one of the challenges how many people
here have worked in cyber security or
done some research and cyber security
and full of people so one of the huge
challenges this is something that you
may run into in your in your data sets
is the is Brown truth is understanding
when so if you're trying to find out
when there was an attack in your data
someone needs to have you know there
needs to be some ground truth associated
with that as much as we'd all love to
sit and write DDoS attacks and port scan
attacks on ourselves sometimes you know
getting that at scale can be very
difficult so for the purpose of this
work we used a synthetic data generator
in which we took real Internet traffic
data but then injected synthetic impacts
into it that would and that was sort of
our way of looking for establishing
ground truth so the Maori working group
actually does published ground truth
based on a number of
that they have a lot of these are
heuristics based detectors in our in our
you say now looking at that ground truth
it was really difficult to actually
understand when an attack was occurring
you know sort of like somewhere in this
hour an attack occurred which if you're
trying to chain the machine learning
classifier on that or an anomaly
detector that's kind of vague right
because there's a lot happening in an
hour of Internet traffic and so if it's
somewhere in that hour an attack
occurred that can be very difficult to
find so that's sort of a reason that we
focused on using a synthetic attack
generator yep
pieces a little bit more about what kind
of guys contracted so you know is just
evident where you're joining some
colorized post that it's injecting data
to some destination
is there also like return clothes that
are in there yeah yeah so the question
that was asked is you know I guess how
sophisticated is this tool and how
detailed can you do it so the exact
details of that I would you know
probably forward you to Emily but from
looking at what what was being done
these are reasonably sophisticated so
it's not as simple as you know you have
to give it a text file of all the IP
addresses sourcing so but you do have to
set some parameters so what you can do
for example if it's a DDoS attack right
that's maybe the easiest one to describe
is you would give it a maybe a range of
IP addresses and ports that you'd like
to see injected you'd give it a flow
rate and then you could tell it what
type of package you'd like introduced
and has it sort of allows you to do a
number of these different this
particular tool at least allows you to
pick a number of these different
features that it then injects into the
original pcap file if you're looking for
some of the other attacks so this is
just a list of the attacks that that
they currently support as of a few
months ago and they might be adding to
this you know we focus on a few of these
that that were also easy for us to
reason and kind of go back into the
actual data that we collected to see if
the actual injection made sense to us or
not but they do have a number of
different parameters that you could that
you could
when you're doing that so that's just a
little bit you know as we talked about
in the data conditioning phase of
labeling data is often a pretty
difficult process in the world of cyber
anomaly in the world of network network
packets and network security going back
and trying to label is an extremely
time-consuming task and very difficult
and up to a lot of interpretation as to
what one calls an attack so what we did
manually inspect a few of these that's
certainly not scalable so we decided to
go with a synthetic attack generator and
I'm sure some of your projects you may
also kind of think about you know is
that it is that a route that you need to
take at least to start off with ok so
this is the overall pipeline of the
system so as I mentioned the first time
we chatted we spent a majority of our
time in sort of the first step which is
the first step here which is which is
data conditioning which is data
conditioning so within data conditioning
we did you know taking the raw data
which is downloading this from the
internet this comes to you in a binary
format which is a dot pcap for those who
are familiar with a packet capture
outputs that's that binary format that
comes from like TCP dump for example we
then convert that pcap file into flows
parse that into human readable form
feature engineer training machine
learning classifier do the same thing
with the synthetic data and then get
good results we hope
so step one a beta condition was to
download the actual raw data the data
was downloaded in a compressed binary
format which is probably what a lot of
you will get your hands on typical size
of a single zipped file or typical
compressed files about 2.2 and 1/2 K
when you decompress that it goes to
about 10 gigs about 4x and a single pcap
file corresponds to such about 10 gig
for about 15 minutes worth of traffic so
if you're trying to do multiple days you
can imagine how this starts to explode
in terms of volume and about 15 minutes
you know on average is about 150,000
pack but it corresponds to about 150,000
packets per second so this is a
reasonable amount of network traffic
that we're getting our hands on but even
close to the types of volume that
large-scale providers have to deal with
on a regular basis once we have the
actual what once we have the the pcap
file downloaded just the network packets
don't really tell us much it's tough to
do things with so what we want to do is
convert this into a representation
that's useful to do analysis and so a
lot of work has been done using network
flows and a network flow is essentially
a sequence of packets from a single
source to destination so as you can
imagine when you're streaming a YouTube
video for example it's not one big
packet that comes to you but it's a
series of packets and so flow
essentially tries to detect that and say
ok all of these things was a person
watching this video rights from this
source to this destination within some
time window is defined as a network flow
and so we convert each of these
15-minute pcap files into network flow
representation using a tool called GAF
which stands for yet another flow meter
and so that that helps us do some of
this
you know flow establishing these network
flows and so the size of about 15
minutes worth of flows goes to about two
gigabytes and we set a timeout of flow
to be about five minutes okay once we
have the flows they're still in this
binary format we need to now convert
them into a representation that we can
look at so flow comes with an ASCII
converter called ASCII sorry yeah comes
with a ASCII converter called yaks key
and that essentially converts the data
from this floor representation into a
tabular form and if there's one lesson
that I think Jeremy will talk to you a
lot about next is tables tables tables
people love looking at tabular data it's
very easy to understand I wouldn't
recommend it but you could open this up
in Excel a huge but it would open up but
it's very easy to kind of look at
especially when we're trying to
establish truth in the data to go back
and take a look at it so far for our
pipeline we take the java files
converted into text files each of these
ASCII table so again about 15 minutes
worth of data is about 8 gigabytes in
size and we record a number of different
container pieces for flow we're going to
the details but if you're interested you
can kind of look at what constant what
are the various entities or features
that come up in a network flow alright
so now that we have
network flows that's that sort of like
sort of part one of data conditioning
right we've converted into some
representation that makes sense we have
in a human readable form sort of step
one data conditioning done now the next
thing is to convert it into something
that actually makes sense for our
machine learning algorithm and so this
is sort of bucketed into the area of
feature engineering when we kind of
think back at it and so feature
engineering is really really important
you'll spend a lot of time doing this on
new datasets so each of these flows
contains about 21 different features and
one of the end we need to look for
essentially which of these features make
sense for us to pass into a machine
learning model others we're just going
to end up training an unknown Z so we
have to use some domain knowledge right
where we talk to experts in
cybersecurity and say well you know IP
address this kind of an important thing
but maybe this other flag not as
important and then we use a lot of trial
and error and luck as well to help make
some of these features once we have
these once we kind of pick a set of
features that we're interested in when
we look back at the anomaly detection
literature a lot of work has been done
with this concept of you know you have
these flows but you need to convert them
into some some other format that makes
sense to look for a long lizard so just
converting into a feature space in which
Menominee's makes sense and so we looked
at using entropy and the basic intuition
behind this is that if we if the we're
looking at various flows between
different fields and that the entropy of
these flows should be roughly equal
should be roughly similar should be
about the same not equal that should be
unchanging when there is no big
mechanism defined by an outlier
detection mechanism that's involved with
changing the entropy so for example
right just to make this more clear if
you're having a DDoS attack this is
typically a number of different source
IPM
attempting to talk to a single
destination IP address so you would
expect to see an increase in the entropy
of the source IP field in that
particular example and enforced and
attacks you would probably see something
on the destination port entropy would go
up right that's a little bit of
intuition so a little bit more
complicated than that but that's a very
high-level view of what's going on and
for entropy we just use the standard you
know sure many of you are familiar with
information theory are very familiar
with Shannon entropy and we compute the
flow associated with each of the
features that we paid from the network
flow before so from the feature
engineering we pick to some set of
features associated to that we all
remember what neural networks are this
is just there for completeness so we
take these now network flows these these
entropy associated with the network flow
we use those as input features for a
neural network model now you'll recall
recall from the neural network talk that
we had last week we have inputs and
outputs we have weights associated with
them and then we have this nonlinear
equation that sort of represents inputs
and outputs and inputs and output that
each of the layers there's the equation
you can see very giving me the Q that
I'm walking towards the slides
so the features that loops the features
that we have over here correspond to the
various entropies that we've computed in
the previous step and the outputs of
this network correspond to a class of
attack
so in particular we focused on you know
obviously no attack DDoS attacks port
scans network scans and p2p network
scans the model itself had three hidden
layers with 130 and 100 mils
respectively
and an output layer and we used for illu
activation I'm having to talk in more
depth about why we selected these but
I'll save that for another time and kind
of going through this process we
actually had very good results so that's
a sort of the short form of the research
work but what I wanted to really
emphasize is the amount of effort that
went into the data conditioning the
importance of you know collecting data
anonymizing data making it you know
human readable converting into a format
that people understand and then kind of
walking through this sort of it was
certainly an iterative process as much
as this is a very short form of what we
did this this took a long time to get to
these results and what we're presenting
over here is the attack type and
intensity so this is the ground truth
from the synthetic data generator and
then this is sort of the prediction that
our model has across the site and this
is a confusion matrix so a higher number
or a darker blue indicates that we did a
really good job and we've also used
varying
ten cities of these an attack so
certainly if we have strong which means
we injected about twenty thousand
packets in the fifteen minutes we can we
can detect those are really really well
as you have weaker weaker attacks of our
system doesn't do as well as probably
reasonable but certainly an area of one
important research so with that I just
wanted to hand it over to Jeremy but
these are some initial work and results
of detecting across line Network attacks
the keynotes was you know data
conditioning was where we ended up
spending a majority of the time cleaning
up the collected data coming up with we
struck we spent a lot of time trying to
figure out how to label this data
because we were just unable to really do
it and finally we ended up going the
synthetic generator path but you know we
actually did spend a significant amount
of time try to figure that out and then
we spend a lot of time on feature in
engineering which did consist of a lot
of trial and error okay thank you
okay thank you very much I'm Jeremy
Konner
from Lincoln Laboratory supercomputing
Center most of you know me already just
really introducing myself for video and
this has been this topic has been teed
up really well by Sid and Vijay I think
they Illustrated sort of going from if
we think about our pipeline going from
left to right so they've talked about
kind of the end state that what you're
trying to do building these models
Vijay talked about the data that feeds
into that I'm going to talk about the
data architecture that you go through to
kind of build up to that and the reason
we've done it in this order which is the
reverse order that you do it in real
life is because it's difficult to
appreciate the data architecture piece
without an understanding of where you're
going and so you see from SIDS talk I
think it became very clear that having
lots of data is really important for
creating these models without the data
you can't you can't do anything
and likewise you didn't see it but all
that data was created in a very precise
form that made it easy to do that kind
of work and then vijay talked a little
about some of things given a data set
what did he have to do to get in a form
such that it would work for his AI
training application and what vijay is
doing and did in that application is
very much a sort of microcosm of which
many of you will be doing in your own
projects you will try to identify data
sets you will try and do feature in
engineering and then go through this
sort of trial and error process of
coming up with AI models that suits on
purpose and a key part of that is what
we call AI data architecture so i'm
going to talk about some of the things
that we've learned over the last ten
years in data architecture as a head of
a supercomputing Center I have the
privilege of working with really
everyone at MIT on all their data
analysis problems and over the years
we've learned some techniques some
really simple techniques that can
dramatically make data architecture for
your applications a lot
there's a lot of people out there
selling very fancy software to solve
data architecture problems we have found
that we can use very simple techniques
to solve most of those problems using
software that's built into every single
computer that that is made today
that's don't need to go and download
some new tool to do any of the things
I'm going to talk about right now so
with that introduction I'm going to just
go over there's the outline of my talk
I'm going to add some introduction and
motivation which I'll go through quickly
because I think Sid and Vijay did a
fantastic job of motivating what we're
doing and then I'm going to talk about
our serve three big ideas and how to
make AI data architecture simple and
effective across a wide range of
applications one is and as Vijay talked
about we're going to really hit this
concept of tabular data there's a reason
why tabular data is so good and why it
is such a preferred format and so you
want to try and get your data into these
tabular formats and the nice thing is
that should that should that if that
sounds really simple it's because it is
really simple lots of people that want
you to buy tools that make this process
complicated because that's how they
inject themselves in the process and
we've discovered actually you can do
world-class MIT quality AI org
with really really simple tools getting
things in a tabular
starting and then how to organize the
data how to organize the data in the
pipeline that Vijay showed which is
pretty standard across a lot of
applications again there's lots of
applications and tools that will try to
do that for you we've just found that
simple folder naming and file naming
schemes get you a long way they require
no tools and they make it really easy
for other people to join your project
because they can just look at the data
and it's pretty clear what's going on
and it also makes the data easy to share
so that's another simple thing and then
finally I want to talk about every
single application we've demoed here
involve datasets that were designed for
sharing designing your data is such that
you can give it to others actually
addresses a lot of the data architecture
problems that you will encounter
yourself by thinking about okay how do I
make this data such that I could give it
to someone else you're really making it
much better product for yourself if
you're making it to the other people can
join your team much more quickly and be
much more effective and so thinking
about sharing of data is really an
important thing and what you'll discover
is that generalized sharing of data is
very hard just pointing to a data set
and saying I want to share it is very
challenging there's a lot of barriers to
do that
but if you have some idea with the end
purposes with the particular application
that you want to share this data for
then it becomes a lot easier both
technically and administrator
and we will talk a little bit about some
of the administrative burdens that you
need to go through to share data and
this is where knowing the purpose in
this case we want to do particular AI
application dramatically simplifies the
the process of doing data shown so just
some motivation this is a slide that
Vijay presented earlier and the big
thing to emphasize here is we have a
bunch of breakthroughs and the key is
the bottom row which says that the time
from algorithm to breakthrough is like
two decades but the time from getting
data set that is a shareable well
architected data set to breakthrough was
much much shorter was only three years
and so that's kind of motivation for the
fact that why data is so important to
making progress in AI the data is
actually writing the program as vijay
mentioned in the first lecture and so
having data is really important and it
has been often observed that eighty
percent of the effort associated with
building an AI system is data wrangling
or data architecture as we call it and
one of the benefits of these challenge
problems that are these open and
shareable datasets is they have done a
lot of that data architecture and data
wrangling
for the community which is why they're
able to have a lot of people work on it
and make progress on it if you're doing
a new application you have to do this
data architecture data wrangling
yourself and and we're going to share
with you the techniques for doing that
effectively and I would say in most
situations this 80% of the effort
actually is going to discovering the
methods that we are going to cover in a
few minutes
that is it takes people a long time to
figure out how simple tables are good we
can organize our data that way and just
having a good set of folder names and
file names really solves most of the
problems right that's the beauty of the
solution is sound so phenomenally simple
how could it possibly work that's
actually you know if there's one thing
we figured out here at MIT is that
simple can be very good and very
powerful so as was mentioned before sort
of these neural networks as depicted
here dry this space of applications most
of the innovations we've seen in the
past few years have been using these
neural networks this one slide sort of
covers all of neural networks and one
slide you have the the picture you have
the input features which are shown in
grey dots you have the output
classifications that are shown in blue
dots and then you have their neural
network and all their various weight
matrices or weight tables in the
if you had one goal in terms of
understanding AI making a commitment to
understanding this one slide and you
pretty much understand a good fraction
of the entire field and while you are
here at MIT please feel free to talk to
any of us about this slide or these
concepts and we will work with you to
help you understand it because anyone
who's ever coming to you and offering an
AI solution that uses neural networks
which is a significant fraction them
they're just doing this this is all
they're doing it's all on this one slide
many of them by the way do not know the
math that the one equation here that sin
does they have software they play with
knobs but they don't even understand the
underlying mathematics and just
understanding this math taking the time
to do it you will know more than anyone
who is actually trying to sell you AI
solutions
now as a Sid said you talk about back
sighs I just added batches to this
figure to emphasize the fact that all of
these letters are mostly uppercase and
if you want to know one thing about
matrix math is the easiest way to go
from a vector equation to a matrix
equation is take all the lowercase
letters and make them uppercase and most
of the time that actually just works in
fact typically what we do if you're a
linear algebraic person is we do that
and see if it breaks anything and if it
doesn't break anything while we assume
it's right and all these matrices right
are tabular a matrix it's just a big
table it's a pretty big spreadsheet so
basically all of neural networks and AI
is just about taking spreadsheets and
transforming them and so this is just
motivation for why these tables are so
important here is this standard pipeline
Vijay talked about it briefly and again
what we've discovered is that in most
data analysis which includes AI this
pipeline represents pretty much what
most applications are doing it's not
that any application does all of that
but most of the steps in an application
fall into this pipeline basically you
have raw data you parse it usually into
some tabular format you may ingest it
into a database you then query that
database for a subset to do analysis or
you might scan the whole
database if you're doing all the files
if you want to do some application and
involve all the data and then you
analyze it and then you visualize it and
so this is sort of the big steps in a
pipeline that we see and again most
applications we'll see will use three of
these steps they're not using all of
them but it's a great framework for
looking at any data analysis pipeline
it's easy to use it's easy to understand
and it's easy to maintain and those are
we you know we like all of those
features and I'll get into those more
data and more more detail and then
finally I've already talked with
significantly about data sharing those
are some examples of the data we put up
for sharing the moments and time
challenge the graph challenge and again
creating sharing quality data really
it's not just a service to the community
it's principally a service to yourself
and in fact we've worked with a number
of applications and sponsors where we
help them do this and they find the data
than they made shareable is instantly
the most valuable data in their
organization because it's shareable
within their organization to the same
things that make it shareable to the
broader community make it shareable
within your organization to other
partners especially important
and again as I said before Co designing
the sharing and the purpose of the data
is quite if you need to do that in order
to do a fective sharing you can't just
sort of share data arbitrarily it's not
to be very difficult to do but if you
have a particular application in mind
sharing the data is quite simple and
I'll get into that later so I'm just
gonna then sort of hammer home some of
these points here so nothing really new
here just through repeating what I've
already said about these things but with
having a little bit more attachment to
them so why do we like tables well we've
been using tables to analyze data for
thousands of years so on the right is a
12th century manuscript it's actually a
table of tides and if you could read
Latin and Roman numerals you already can
tell that it's probably oh there's some
column there's some roads and those
Roman numerals or numbers even 800 years
later we can still see that this is a
data table and it goes back further you
can find Kamiya form tablets that are
thousands of years old that are clearly
written in a tabular form so humans have
been looking at data in a tabular form
for for thousands of years part of that
is to how our brain is actually wired
one the 2d projections since we live in
3d space is the only projection that
will show you all the data without
occlusion so if you want to look at all
the day that kind of has to be presented
in 2d form we have a 2d optical system
in addition we have special hardwired
parts of our eyes the detective vertical
and horizontal lines for presumably
detecting the horizon or trees or who
knows what and that makes it very easy
for our eyes to look at tabular data and
because of this tag their data is
compatible with almost every data
analysis software on earth if I make
data analysis software they can't read
tables or write out tables it's going to
have a very small market share and this
is just an example of some of the
software out there that is designed to
use tables so whether it be spreadsheets
or databases for the neural network
packages that we've already looked at
various languages and libraries and even
things that you wouldn't think are
tabular like hierarchical file formats
like JSON and XML can actually be made
compatible with a tabular format so I'm
just going to walk through these a
little more detail so of course our
favorite is spreadsheets here's an
example of a spreadsheet on the left and
what's great about it is that I have
four different types of data that are
very very different and you can all look
at them and sort of
sense of what they long and that just
shows how flexible this tabular
spreadsheet form is is that we can
really it can handle really really
diverse types of data in a way that's
intuitive to us some of the biggest
pieces of software that are you that the
implements are Microsoft Excel Google
sheets Apple numbers it's used by about
a hundred million people every day and
so this is the most popular tool for
using data analysis and there's a good
reason for it and thinking of things in
a tabular format so they can be pulled
into this really makes communication a
lot easier and so again just from
hammering home this element of tables
within that there's specific formats
that we found to be very popular
so CSV and tsp are just not proprietary
plain text ways of organizing data we
highly encourage people to use them
because then it can be used by any tool
CSV just stands for comma separated
values it's usually file name dot CSV in
lower case or file name ducks use to be
in uppercase and on all it means is that
the columns so each each row is
terminated by a newline and within each
row the columns are separated by a comma
that's all that means we tend to
encourage people to use TSV which stands
for tab-separated values because we can
replace the comma with a tab and that
allows us to write higher-performance
readers and writers because it is not
uncommon to have
within a value and so it makes it very
difficult to sort of write parsers that
can do that fast but it's okay to say to
a person generating data if you put a
tab inside a value that's a file a lot
you you should do that and so that means
I can read some I can write a program
that can read this data really fast and
it can write this data really fast and
that's why in sort of the big data AI
space people often tend to use a TSP and
again it's easily readable and writable
by all those spreadsheet programs that I
have said before databases play a very
important role as well there's several
different kinds of types of databases
that are called SQL no sequel a new
sequel they're good for different things
I won't dwell on that here but there are
different types of databases all of them
operate on tables in fact the central
object in a Navis is literally called a
database table and so native aliases
play an important role I won't go into
detail here but I just want to mention
this likewise you've already had some
demonstrations of different languages
and libraries think everything you saw
was in Python there's other languages
Giulia MATLAB octave are many other
languages that play important roles and
data analysis we've talked about Jupiter
notebooks which is a universe
so interface to these different
languages and libraries to allow you to
do data analysis in addition to the
various machine learning tools we've
talked a lot about tensorflow but
there's others they on Oh cat cafe and
video digits all are examples of
different tools for doing AI and again
they love to ingest tabular data and
they're very good at writing out tabular
data completely consistent with with
here and then finally I want to mention
XML and JSON which are very popular in
object oriented languages like C++ Java
and Python those languages rely on data
structures which are basically just a
set of fields and then those fields can
also be data structures and this can
continue on these are called
hierarchical data structures the way
these languages are organized and so
it's very natural for them to have
formats that they can just say write out
this whole blob of data and it'll write
it out into a hierarchical form called
XML or JSON
however it's not very human readable and
I just told you that all the data
analysis tools want tables which means
that these formants aren't necessarily
very good for doing data analysis on
fortunately we've discovered some ways
that we can basically convert these
hierarchical formats into a giant what
we call sparse table and sparse just
means a table where lots of the value
entry or I'm sorry are empty thought of
the entries are empty and so we can just
use that space to represent this
hierarchy and all the tools we've just
talked about can adjust this data pretty
easily because tables are so popular
every single different approach or
software package and they have a bunch
of them list listed in the in the first
column here assign different names to
the standard ways we refer to the
elements of a table and there aren't
that many so when you think about a
table there's certain standard terms for
dealing with what do we call the table
in Excel it's called a sheet what we
what do we how do we refer to a
particular row what do we call a whole
row how do we refer to a particular
column what do we call the whole column
what do we call an entry and what kind
of math can we do on it and so whenever
you're encountering a new piece of
software and we deal with it all the
time a lot of times it gets offered and
maybe it's related to data analysis it
seems really really confusing it's
probably working on tables and so all
you have to need to learn is what are
they calling these things and different
software gives different names just for
arbitrary historical reasons and so if
you can figure out what what it's
calling these things then you'll
discover that the software is a lot
easier to understand so we definitely
encourage you to to just map whatever
software into these concept and all the
sudden life becomes a lot easier
and because tabular data is used so
commonly whether it be in spreadsheets
or analyzing graphs or databases or
matrices it's a natural interchange
format so by reading in tabular data and
writing out tabular data you're
preserving your ability to have that
soft that data go into any application
again you have to be careful about
people who want to write proprietary
formats because they're basically sort
of preventing you from basically working
with other tools and other communities
and this is another reason why tabular
data is so great all right so moving on
here I want to just talk about basic
files and folders so hopefully you two
becoming tables are good that's sort of
lesson one and we're going to talk about
how files and folder names well-chosen
is also good right again this sounds so
obvious but it is really the thing that
we've discovered is working with
thousands of MIT
Searchers over the past decade that
these are the sort of fundamentals that
told you out I've already mentioned this
pipeline that you talked about it's a
way we organize the the data it's easy
to build it has built-in tools in every
single computer you have to support this
to just create folders and files that
means it has no technical back that is
you never have to worry about if you
have folders and files that in ten years
oh my god
folders and files are gonna go away
they've been around for 50 years in
pretty much their present form we don't
anticipate them changing they're easier
to understand I was talking about
tablets already talking about tabular
file formats and how useful they are and
we will talk about a simple naming
scheme for your data files ai requires a
lot of data which means often thousands
or millions of files having good schemes
for naming them really helps you and
helps share the data amongst people in
your team they can just look at the
folders and files and I sort of
understand what's going on and again
this folder structure is very easy to
maintain
it doesn't require any special
technology and anyone can look at it
getting into some more detail about
those table formats some sort of real
truth in the weeds types of things that
are really important if I just talked
about you wanna avoid proprietary
formats if you can using CSV and
see are great they might be a little
bulkier you can compress them no problem
with doing that then you get pretty much
all the benefits of a proprietary format
but in a way that's generally usable
within a within a TSP or CSV file it's
good practice to make sure that each
column label is unique so that that's
actually a big help you don't want to
have essentially the same column label
or column name occur over and over again
and likewise is helpful if if the first
column are the row labels and those are
each unique as well and just those two
practices make it a lot easier to to
read and organize the data otherwise you
end up having to do various
transformations if a lot of the entries
are empty ie the table is very sparse
there's another format we use which is
called sometimes called triples format
basically every single entry in the
table can be referred to by its row
label its column label and its value
that's forms a triple so you can just
write another file can be a TSP file
that has three columns the first column
is the row label the first column is the
next the next column is a column label
and the next column is the value label
and most software can read this in
pretty nicely it's a very convenient way
dealing with very very sparse data
without losing any benefits so that's a
very good thing in terms of actual file
naming as I said before you want to
avoid having lots of tiny files most
file systems most data systems do not
work with small files really well you do
want to compress that decompression
doesn't take much time it's usually
quite beneficial and so it's better to
have fewer larger files a sweet spot for
a long time has been filed sort of in
the 1 Vega byte 200 megabyte range this
1 megabyte is big enough so that you can
read it in and give high bandwidth get
the data into your program quickly and
up to a hundred megabyte once you start
going beyond that you maybe can start
exhausting the memory of your computer
or your processor and so this is 1
megabytes a 100 megabyte range has been
a sweet spot for quite a while you want
to keep directories 2 less than a
thousand files that's pretty common
nowadays creating directories with a
really large number of files files so
most systems don't really like that
you'll find it's also hard to work with
and so that's something you want to keep
your directories less than a thousand
and so you do that by using hierarchical
directories and so when it comes to
naming files to things that tend to be
pretty Universal is source and time of
data right there's when you when you
call it where you collected it
when you collected it are pretty
fundamental aspects that you can rely on
being a part of almost all of datasets
and so this is a simple naming scheme
that we use that we find is very
accessible we just create a hierarchical
directory here begins with source and
then we have the years the months the
days the hours and this however far you
need to go to kind of hit your sort of
thousand files per folder window and
then we repeat all that name but from
the file name itself so there's the file
ever gets separated from its directory
structure you still have that
information and that's really important
because it's easy for files to get
separated and then you know it's like a
kid wandering around without his parents
so but if it's got a little label on it
you know it says this is my address then
you can get that get the kid back home
so and likewise sometimes you'll do the
time first and then source it really
depends on the application they're both
both fun but this again it sounds really
simple but it it solves a lot of
problems if you give data to people in
this form they're going to know what it
means right it doesn't require a lot of
explanations like dates are pretty
obvious source names are pretty obvious
and then they can basically work through
it pretty nicely
my databases and files can work together
you'll have some people like we do
everything with files or we do
everything with databases they do
different things they serve different
purposes so databases are good for
quickly finding a small amount of data
being a big data set so if I'm going to
look up a little bit of data and a big
data set that's what databases do well
likewise if I want to read a ton of data
like all of the data and I want to
analyze
that's what file systems do well so you
a lot of times keep them both around you
have databases for looking up little
elements quickly and you have files in
data and file system if I want to read a
lot of data so they work together very
harmoniously they serve different
purposes and again different databases
are good for different things I won't be
later these you can read them yourself
but there are a variety of database
technologies out there they serve
different purposes so let me talk about
the folder structure a little bit more
detail this is getting really like it is
really just this simple when we talk
about our standard pipeline it's just a
bunch of folders that we made like we
show on the right so every unit we have
an overall folder that we usually call
pipeline
and then we basically labeled each step
with step zero step one so people know
which is the beginning and which is the
end and what's happening in there so we
have steps you're a rock step one parts
step to ingest step three query step for
analysis step five five is it is [ __ ]
if you're doing that and then within
each one of those within each one of
these will have a folder will have a
readme which basically tells people
something about okay what's going on
there
those reading these are really good even
if you never share this data with
anybody else as you get on in life you
will often be asked to revisit things
and just having this information so that
two years later you can go back and look
at it is really really helpful and
because otherwise you'll discover that
you don't remember what it is you were
doing so you write a little read
easement to give you some information
about what's going on and then within
each staff there's usually read me that
talk to you about what the instructions
in here and then we have a folder called
code and folder called data and
basically the code describes how you put
data into this folder so in the step 0
raw this is often the code maybe for
downloading the data from the internet
or down or how you collected the data
that's the code that basically puts the
data into that folder and then with
in the next hole to hear parse this is
the code that takes this raw data and
parses it and puts it into this folder
and then for ingest you know this will
be the code that takes the data from the
parsed form sticks to the database and
these might be the log files of the
database entry so a lot of times when
you ingest data into a database you'll
have log files in the keep track of what
that happened and likewise this
continues on down so very simple and you
and I would offer to you if you someone
gave you this and you looked at it
without any documentation you probably
have a pretty good idea of what's going
on oh this is some kind of pipeline I
wonder where it begins probably step 0 I
wonder what that is it's probably raw
data right it's that simple
and this just makes it so easy the more
you can give stuff to people and they
could just understand it without any
additional explanation that's incredibly
valuable and again allows your teams to
contribute quickly to projects and then
finally we'll add a little thing here
which is a data file list this is a list
of the full names of all the data files
because especially on our systems people
are often processing lots of data which
contain millions of files if you're
going to be using many processors to do
that it's it really punishes the file
system if you ask a thousand processors
to all Traverse
a data directory and build up the file
name so they can figure out which files
they should each process that really
that's actually a great way to get
kicked off a computer is to have a
thousand processes all doing LS dash L
on all the folders in a directory with
millions of files right people bring the
file system to its knees so if you just
have this one file that you generate
once and lifts all the names of the
files then every single process can just
read in that file pick up which files
they want to read and then do their work
and then even know what the names to
write the files are and that's really a
very efficient way dramatically speeds
up your processing and keeps the
pressure on the file system at a minimum
in addition if you just want to look at
what you have you don't have to type LS
to list the directory which might take a
while you could just look in this file
and see what what do I have right it's
very convenient to be able to know what
what the datasets
alright you could go in there you see oh
I see all these you know timestamps and
sources I know what I have right it
makes it really easy for people to get
through this so finally I want to talk
about using a charity and so again
co.design using and sharing together
most data that she will deal with starts
out unusable and um shareable as the
data is not suited for the perf
you wanted to use it for and do not have
permission to share it with anybody and
so if you understand the data and its
purpose you can get through both of
those problems so really practical
aspects here of data sharing we're gonna
talk about a few different roles that
are very common in data sharing the
first is the keeper of the data this is
the actual person who has the ability to
make the copy of the data you can talk
to lots of people but until you find the
keeper of the data you haven't really
gotten anywhere right because logs as oh
yes we have data and we can share it or
we can give it to its center and there's
someone who can eventually type a copy
command to the data you want to find
that person that's the person you really
need to work with they're the one person
who can really really help you because
they actually have hands-on access to
the data so you want to find that then
you want to get a sample or copy the
data to your team to assess it is
always good to do good OPSEC which is
good operational security which means
fewer accounts fewer people having
access is better a lot of times people
say oh here's the data give me a list of
names that you want to have access to it
if you provide them one name that's
often pretty easy to get approved if you
provide ten names now questions will
happen why are we giving ten people
access to this data you don't really
need ten people to have access to the
data you can just have one person get
the data on after the team that's
relatively easy to prove you start
giving a list of twenty names have
accidents and that might just end the
exercise right there and once the
question starts happening you'll
discover well maybe we've lost that
money and we need to move on to someone
else
so and guess what that keeper do they
like you now that they've raised all
kinds of questions because something
they thought was okay well now we're
people no you may no longer have a
friend right so you've lost a friend
you've lost the sorts of data so
minimizing the access to the data
getting just the people access to who
need you to make it to make your next
step really good practice I have been
that keeper I had been the person who
has to approve
and nothing makes me sort of shut
something down quicker than someone says
well I want 20 people to have a census
I'm like well no zero works for me
that's a that's a number in 20 right
that's one of the numbers there how
about zero that works for me so then
once you get a copy of the data you then
convert a sample of it to a tabular form
you can identify the useful columns or
features in that and then you can get
rid of the rest that's a huge service to
your community is if you have a volume
of data you know like all of this stuff
is not going to be useful now you're
just giving people useful data that's
really really valuable that's sort of
written and since you're talking to
keeper of the data they may have the
most information about what these
different columns or features mean
that's not a conversation that a lot of
people are going to get to have and so
you get to help your whole team by
saying oh we know these columns mean
this they're not relevant let's get rid
of them that's a huge service to your
community it's less data it makes it
easier to release you then make it well
if there are is data columns or features
that are sensitive in some way there's a
variety of techniques you can use to
minimize anonymize possibly simulate or
use surrogate information to make it so
that you can share that data
and there's lots of techniques but we
need those are only applicable when you
know your application so if I look at
this data and I see this one column that
might be sensitive but valuable for my
application I can often come up with a
minimization scheme that will work for
that because all data analysis based on
tables which is mathematically just
matrices one of the fundamental
properties of matrices that we really
really like is that reordering the rows
of the columns doesn't change any of the
math that's kind of like the big deal of
matrices and tables you can move the
Rope reorder the roads really columns
and everything should still just work
which means if you re label the columns
or leave re label the rows things should
still just work and you'll get the be
able to do the science you need so a lot
of times when you share data with
researchers information that normally
you would delete that you would think
would be valuable someone else the
reasons like I don't care right
it doesn't change as long as it doesn't
change fun something fundamental about
the structure of the data I can work
with that and again that's something you
would never know unless you have an in
purpose in mind so then you want to
obtain a preliminary approval to take
and I have the data set I've worked with
the keeper is OK for me to share this
the broader set of people to make sure
that they they like it too that's
usually easy
it's just a small sample and then you
can test with your AI users you repeat
this process until you basically have
Dan's like if this is what we want this
is we want to share and then you can
sort of go through the process of how do
we really get an agreement in place to
do that you also then create the folder
naming structure for scaling out to more
data files and then finally what's great
is if you can then automate this process
process at the Dana Boehner's site it's
tremendously valuable then you have just
gifted them a data architecture that
makes their data AI ready and then
moving forward they can now share with
you within their own organization or
with others right so this is incredibly
valuable right we said data architecture
and wrangling is often 80% of the effort
you do this you've now eliminated
potentially 80% of the efforts of anyone
else who ever wants to do data analysis
of AI on this data right this is a
phenomenally huge win for anyone that
you partner with is to give them a very
simple data architecture they can
maintain going forward it's a huge
savings to them alright so another roll
we want to talk about is the data on our
subject matter expert or Smith so we've
talked about the keeper of the data
there's often a subject matter expert
but associated with the data that is an
advocate right the keepers often like to
pay I maintain the data I do with these
subject matter experts tell me to do but
there's someone out there who's wants to
help you get the data because they see
it's going to be valuable to you and all
these AI data products are generally
best made by people with am knowledge so
it's we're highly motivated to engage
with these subject matter experts pull
them into the AI community so they can
see the best practices that will allow
them to understand which data they have
how it might be useful to AI and how it
how to prepare it so that's better so
whenever we get engaged with subject
matter experts and other communities you
know at data owners we really want to
pull them into the community have them
come to our environment so they can see
what's going on and help us identify new
data sets and help make those data sets
appropriate for our consumption so one
of the big things you'll run into is
that there are concerns with sharing
data that is there's a lot of confusion
about the liability of sharing data with
researchers and data owners often have
to think about the lowest common
denominator if it's a company they have
to think about us and he
and other requirements all kinds of
different frameworks for thinking about
that the good news is there are standard
practices that meet these requirements
and I'm going to list what these
standard practices are we have worked
with many folks who've tried to share
data successfully and these are the
properties of successful data sharing
activities and the activities that don't
do these things often are unsuccessful
we didn't invent any of this this is
just our observations from working with
many people who tried to share data one
you want data available the curated
repositories just taking data and
posting it somewhere without proper
curation really does no good for anyone
you want to use standard anonymization
methods where needed
Aisling sampling simulation I've already
talked about those but those do work
particularly when they are coupled with
access requires registration with a
repository and legitimate need so
there's a data agreement associated with
getting the you know getting the data in
some way shape or form and those two
together really really work well and you
also want to focus on getting the data
to the people who are actually going to
add value to it so one of the misnomers
take data and we'll make it available to
all 10 billion souls on the planet er
when really less than a hundred could
ever actually add value to us so why are
we going through all the trouble and the
issues associated with making data
available to anyone when really we only
want to get that data to people with the
skills and legitimate research needs to
make a use of it and so by setting up
curated repositories people then apply I
want to get access to the data they talk
about what their need is that sets sort
of a swimlane you can't just do anything
you want with the data when you say I'm
going to use it for this purpose you
have to stick to those guidelines if you
want to change them you have to go back
and say look I want to do something
different if you're a legitimate
researcher with legitimate research
needs that's usually pretty easy to
approve and then recipients agree not to
repost the whole data set or to D
anonymize it this is what it makes
anonymization work
not that the anonymization or the
encryption is so strong it's unbreakable
is that people agree not to reverse it
and the good thing about working with
legitimate researchers is they're highly
motivated not to break their agreements
if you're at MIT or any of these
universities and you break your data
sharing agreements that is
professionally very detrimental to you
because it is very detrimental to the
organization no research organization
ever wants to have a reputation that it
does not respect its data usage
agreements that will put that research
organization out of business so there's
a lot of incentive for legitimate
researchers to honor these agreements
which may not be the same
just general people who are in working
in other types of environments so they
can publish their analysis and data
examples as necessary they agree to cite
the repository program provide the
publication's back and their project Ori
can carry enriched products so if a
researcher discovers some derivative
product loci I can apply this to all the
data you know I'd like to have that be
posted somewhere they can often use the
original repository to do that and again
we encourage everyone to encourage
people to follow these guidelines
they're very beneficial so I've talked
about the data keeper I've talked about
the subject matter expert now I'm going
to talk about a final critical role
which is the ISO which is an information
security officer in almost every single
organization that has data there is an
information security officer that needs
to sign off on making the data available
to anyone else
they're the person whose neck is on the
line and saying that it's ok to share
this data
the benefits outweigh the potential
risks and subject matter experts need to
communicate with the information
security officer they're also the ones
advocating for this data to be released
but they don't know the language of
information security officers and this
causes huge problems and I would say 90%
of
sharing efforts died because of
miscommunication between subject matter
experts and information security
officers because the information
security officer fundamentally needs to
believe that the subject matter expert
understands the risk understands basic
security concepts in order for them to
trust them with their signature to get
it released and so typically what hand
happens is that an ISO needs very basic
information from the subject matter
expert in order to approve the release
of information what's the project what's
the need
where is it the data going to be who's
going to be using it for how long they
are expecting one sentence answers to
each of these a subject matter expert
typically replies with an entire
research proposal and so I'm an ISO and
I'm trying to assess whether subject
matter expert knows anything about
security and I gave them really easy
softball questions and they come back
with something that clearly took them
way more time and effort that answers
none of my questions what's my opinion
going to be of that subject matter
expert and how much I should trust them
it's going to be zero and from that
moment onward I'll be polite but you
know how about zero data that works for
me right that's a good number
right so so this is really important and
so if there's one thing we can do
because very few of your ISOs and
something that my team gets involved on
a lot is to intercept this conversation
before it goes bad is we can help you
work work with with ISOs work with
people who have to release with data and
help answer these questions in a proper
way and some go through a few examples
you so a really common question is was
the data you're seeking to share so this
is a very common question to get back
from a nice sub describe the data to be
shared focusing on its risk to the
organization if it were to be
accidentally released with the public or
otherwise misuse very common question
and so here's an example answer very
short answer the data was collected on
these dates at this location in
accordance with our mission the risk has
been assessed and addressed by an
appropriate combination of excision
anonymization and/or agreements they're
released to appropriate legitimate
researchers will further our mission and
is endorsed by leadership very very very
short answer but we've covered a lot of
ground in that short answer now explain
sentence 1 establishes the identity
finite scope and proper collection of
the data in one sense sends 2
establishes that risk was assessed in
the mitigations were taken sentence
three establishes the finance coppa the
recipients and appropriate reasons for
release and mission approval we've
covered we've answered nine questions in
three sentences at the level of detail
and ISO ones
I can always ask you more questions for
more detail and they're usually looking
for another one sentence answer and you
build these up to be three four five
sentence things that cover broadly what
you're wanting to do and you see here
you don't want to do anything that
requires the I so that have detailed
technical knowledge of what you're doing
they're looking for overall scope
overall limiters on what you're doing so
that is somehow contained to a
reasonable risk another question here
that's very common is where to whom is
the data going so please describe the
intended recipients so an example
answers the data will be shared with
researchers at a specific set of
institutions that'll be processed on
those institutions own systems meeting
their institution security policies
which include password controlled access
regular application of system updates
encryption of mobile devices such as
laptops authoritah it accesses the data
will be limited to personnel working as
part of this effort right again you've
covered a lot of ground very simply we
didn't really go into too many details
that are specific to this to this
particular case and then the final one
is what controls are there on further
release either policy or legal so an
example is an acceptable use guidelines
that were
- dia na mais the deal will be provided
to all personnel working on the data
publication guidelines have been agreed
to the Lao for high level stats apply
needs to be published but prohibit
including any individual data records a
set of notional records has been
provided that can be published an
example of the data format but is not
part of the actual data set the research
agreement requires of all that it be
deleted in the end of the agent except
those items retained for publication I'm
not saying you have to use but again
this is another example of what Isis are
expecting you give them language like
this
their confidence swell to the guy I'm
dealing with someone that understands
the risks I'm taking on their behalf and
we can move forward in a very productive
way and if you ever have questions about
how the news is
feel free to talk to my team or other
people or other ISOs who've had to deal
with this we actually are working with a
lot of people on this language a lot of
people in the government to sort of get
these best practices out there we have
socialized this with a fair number of
experts in this field and there's
general consensus is a very good methods
for helping you get data out so that
brings me then the talk so as I said
before data wrangling very important
significant part of the effort analysis
really relies and tap your data so
that's a really good format you can do
it in very simple non proprietary
formats taking you're going to have to
name your folders and file something you
might as well name something that's
really generally usable
and then finally co designing the
sharing and what the intent is at the
same time that's doable
generalized release of data very very
hard tailored release for specific
applications very very doable if you
have good communication from all the
stakeholders as well so these are just
really practical things isn't sort of
fancy AI this is sort of bread and
butter how you actually get data
analysis done and with that I'm happy to
take any questions
you